welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how to meet
that perfect super strong alien partner
who will live for 5 000 years and how
you can be one of many earthlings they
can start a family with over their
lifetime yes you uh you can uh be the
the wife of chris hemsworth for it's
gonna be amazing that the opportunity is
here i'm telling you right now we're
announcing new rocks as a partnership
with match.com and asgard to bring you
your asgardian boo that you always
wanted my name is mt and i'm here today
with off-screen producer brandon what's
going on brandon hello mt you know i
love my wife so much but i'm glad she's
not gonna live for five thousand years
because that's too long
it's true i feel like being married for
over four thousand years i feel like
that's just like your marriage gets i
mean after yeah one thousand
[Music]
yeah you're you're 2654.
things are really dragging out things
are really dragging out you're gonna
need some counseling around that time
most people do
but what's our big question for today
brandon well mt as we approach the
release of thor love and thunder this
summer we're looking forward to learning
uh more about the ever-expanding new
asgard in norway and how the asgardians
are settling into their life here on
earth but the more we think about it the
more we wonder just how the asgardians
are classified here on earth it all
leads us to this week's big question
are the asgardians now official citizens
of earth ooh
that's a really good question because
with their homeworld of asgard
officially destroyed as we saw in four
ragnarok by searcher as part of the
ragnarok cycle the asgardians who
survived ragnarok and the attack by
thanos on their escape ship the
statesmen have found a new home here on
earth in townsburg norway a huge spot in
the mcu i think it's where uh odin came
and dropped the tesseract off like he
just loves norway a lot he just loves
those people and it's considered the
oldest town in norway it has a long
history with asgard and like i said odin
um protected it from the frost giants in
4-1 as we saw in the flashback and used
it as a place to store the tesseract for
hundreds of years one thing real fast
empty that was kind of messed up of of
odin a little bit to be like here's this
thing i'm not gonna tell you what it
does don't ever touch it put it in your
little your wooden church wall
don't let anyone get it and i'm not
gonna tell you how incredibly dangerous
and powerful this thing is
that was kind of that was kind of messed
up that was extra messed up because like
you know we saw in um in the in the
post-credits scene of thor two um one of
the warriors three is like it's not wise
to have so many infinity stones in one
place so you're just gonna put it
amongst the people of norway it's like
hey if someone comes together at least
we won't die
odin has a vault a vault that is secured
it's locked it's guarded by asgardian
guards it's powerful like put it it's
got a destroyer in there that'll melt
your face off if you try and get near it
put it in there don't put it in norway
with some some poor priest who's just
trying to everyone's looking behind our
norwegian wall i'll tell you that
someone is looking behind it you know
who mt the nazis they're coming for you
[Laughter]
nothing behind your wall is safe from
the nazis looking for it my goodness but
now the asgardians have set up shop in
new asgard here on earth what does it
mean to have a race of extraterrestrials
living permanently on our planet this is
our plan like are they official citizens
of norway like get get out of here
you're taking our space build build the
wall around the planet
tony shark wanted a suit of armor around
the world to keep them aliens out
exactly yo i like the time i remember
secret empire when they built a force
field around the planet like the good
old days old hydro cap that's my captain
america
but yeah can they come and go as they
please like can they start families with
regular like human people like let's
just consider all the implications of
having asgardians here on earth starting
with citizenship because in our world if
extraterrestrials showed up one day it
would be like a huge deal but in the mcu
the confirmation of the existence of
aliens and their visitations to planet
earth is pretty old hat by now it's like
all right we saw thor we had the
invasion of the atari we kind of get it
by now it's fine
so to be fair like most of uh the mcu's
you know earthlings interactions with
aliens have not been great they have not
been great interaction
they've been uh pretty pretty terrible
we had the chitari invasion and then
thanos wiping out half of a humanity
the dark elves showing up those are
technically aliens to us right they
tried they showed up messing up stuff
everything but the
you bring up thanos though like he did
show up but he's bad yes he's the only
but a lot of aliens came and fought him
too so they did they did show up we had
something they didn't show up we had uh
the ravagers show up to help it was
really nice um so like not all aliens
are bad don't be racist don't do it okay
don't do it just because we had a lot of
bad experiences are good aliens like you
know yeah yondu he kidnapped peter quill
he
he kidnapped the future person that
would doom the universe from earth he
saved us from hey do not put this on
peter quell this is not peter quill's
fault i mean he protected a green frog
when he was a kid so he's going to
protect the green bird
he's human he's one of us empty we stick
by our peter phillips okay
we we love we love hard we fight hard
okay
we can't help you can't help it that's
what earth is all about baby that's what
it's all about here we go
all right
but none of them have stuck around in a
major way to set up shop but that is
until the asgardians arrived and that
seemed to happen during the blip a
pretty tumultuous time for the planet so
assuming that the asgardians wanted to
claim asylum in norway what are the
steps to actually do that here's how it
works in our world the process of asylum
is handled by the norwegian directorate
of immigration or udi you can apply for
protection or asylum if you're
persecuted or you fear persecution or
inhumane treatment in your home country
considering that as guardian's home
country is pretty much gone they
certainly can't be sent back there like
you can't really be deported back to
rubble in space they can't be like oh
asylum denied go back and they'll be
like where do you want us to go back to
uh just like see i i don't know i can
make a nice blanket with this uh
asteroid rubble um for me to sleep in um
but yeah no since they've been attacked
by hella searcher and thanos at this
point they certainly have a huge case
for protection and to get asylum process
started you have to seek us
again but to get the asylum process
started you have to seek protection from
the police to do this you must be in
norway or at the norwegian border good
news for the asgardians as they are on
the norwegian soil like they're
literally on like the the coast there
and once you apply you can go to the
national arrival center for up to 21
days considering that there are a fair
amount of asgardians seeking asylum all
at once they might have to let them just
stay in townsburg and during their
waiting period you'll talk to the police
provide your personal info and documents
and then go through a health screening
and during this wait period the udi will
decide on your application and if you're
approved you'll be granted a residence
permit as a refugee normally for three
years and the residence permit can be
renewed from here you can apply for
permanent residence it's a pretty good
process in norway to claim asylum
they're very upfront they've got a very
helpful website about it uh and they
seem like very nice people and who
wouldn't seem like super nice people i
might do this
i mean
like i got some people in boston they're
after me i gotta get out of here
i got a huge tab at duncan they're gonna
cut my legs off i gotta get to norway
the actual dunkin donuts he's after me
mr duncan um
duncan is trying to kill me he's trying
to kill me
the world runs on duncan i can't get
away from him
i can't i can't escape him he's gonna
find me
and we certainly have some extenuating
circumstances where he has guardians
considering the long historical and
cultural bond between norway and norse
mythology i doubt that they would turn
them away because like that'd be that'd
be so messed up plus considering the
relative strength and durability of the
asgardians it would be great to have
them on your side because like why not
why not have some new asgardians in the
military let me dope yeah i doubt i
don't like this is great empty and like
this whole process like this is what
they could do legally right but i'm sure
the norwegians would make like a special
occasion kind of thing where it's like
these aliens show up who are part of
their mythology they'd probably be like
yeah come on in you're ours now all you
strong-ass guardians like you can fight
for us now please be honest right and
this is like during the blip too so
they're like yeah we'll take some some
more people especially uh gods we'll
take you come on in come on in seriously
a lot of like i don't know a mayor or
like the president or the leader of
daughters be like hey we don't have a
captain norway who wants to be captain
norway who wants to be kept in norway
it just goes into a bar anybody here
want to be captain norway
but yeah i know i think we were like
super dope to like see like as guardians
as like integrated into the norwegian
culture and like integrated into like
their their army and like integrated to
like their health care system because
like because we saw it in um for the
dark world that like they had these like
super
smart as guardian doctors that were able
to diagnose yeah they used like magic
and stuff to exactly
so like it would be super dope if like
they were integrated into like the
hospital systems like hey we're healing
all these terrible ailments we're saving
so many lives because we're now part of
this country like i never really thought
about because like i always viewed them
as like
very like separated for everyone else
because when we see them in a in like in
the end game it's like all right we're
in our little village like yeah like
we're not really interacting with um the
rest of humanity but like it seems from
this the thor love and thunder trailer
we see king valkyrie dressed up in a
suit um it seems like as guards giving
tours and stuff so like they're very
much
on earth and they're integrating with
earth and like they're not the separated
gods that like gore the god butcher
hates um like we're they're very much
talking to us like it's really cool yeah
there were people living in townsburg so
i'm sure they were like yeah come on in
be a part of our little community uh
we'd love to have you here also could
you look at these giant boulders for us
thank you so much
honestly like i feel like i really want
the ncu to start making like just like
independent films set within the mcu
because i would love to see like a
norwegian filmmaker tackle
what like what it would be like for the
asgardians to just be amongst us and
like how like that changes everyday life
i think they're really fun and since the
yes guardians have stayed in norway and
set up a thriving tourism industry i
think it's safe to assume that they are
norwegian citizens just full out or at
the very least new asgard is considered
an independent city state within norway
[Applause]
[Music]
which would be even doper it's like i
mean like i feel like it makes sense to
give them their independence like i feel
like it's hard to tell god what to do
not to worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want
yeah exactly but that that's like how
the the vatican works mt it's a city
state within
italy and like they have their own
passports and they they have their own
little government i think i think
yeah i think you're right that as
guardians are probably norwegian
citizens or considered citizens of new
asgard which is at least a city-state
within norway and like there are
citizens there and they have a passport
now and that probably means they can
travel as they see fit that is like
literally bizarre like so but i wonder
if like there are asgardians that like
left new asgard to just go wow live in
different parts of the world that's so
crazy to think of i don't know i don't
know if the world would allow that but
that's something to consider right like
if another country would gladly take
them in and be like yeah you can come
live here please i wonder if like
like there's like an entity tracking all
these all these ass guardians like where
they go at all times oh you know you
know swords tracking that oh yeah oh
yeah for sure like yeah that's their one
job
if valkyrie's like why are you guys what
like she finds out she gets super pissed
like you guys are watching us that's
super rude please stop doing that hello
knuckles you have a lot of nerve coming
in here you have a lot of nerve being
alive oh the guy's like we don't like be
watch we like watching you guys don't
watch us we know that there are some
politics involved here and from the news
crawl we saw in spider-man no way home
we also know that these politics are in
turmoil so can the passport carrying as
guardian citizens of new asgard travel
the planet as they see fit what do you
think
i mean they must be allowed to travel i
can't imagine that anyone would stop
them or be like no you can't because
they want to probably keep them happy
and on our side right right so i'm sure
norway would be like yeah you can leave
the if you you got your passport you got
your new asgard passport you can travel
i don't know if every country would let
them in there might be some countries
that are like no we don't want you
coming in here not allowed to come here
i'm sure the u.s would let him come in
because they would love to steal him
away the u.s would love to have his
living really be welcomed
they might they might let him into north
korea i don't know if they let him out i
don't know
[Laughter]
i think i think the ass guardians have
got to be allowed to travel it'd be so
weird to be like no you guys have to
stay in this city you cannot leave
especially if you have all these cruise
lines coming in they just hop on a boat
and get out of there i'm sure they want
to track their travels so they probably
if you told them like no you can't
travel then they're going to sneak out
right and they don't want that so i'm
sure they were like yeah you can travel
but we're going to watch every move and
you know swords watching them for sure
if they got flying goats i'm like on the
ready it's like can you really stop them
you can't stop them yeah
i wouldn't
i wonder if the goats are like
registered with like i don't know all
the planes it's like hey if you see a
flying goat don't worry about it um
pilots yeah it's just uh add new asgard
they might be they might be forced to
fly below a certain altitude you know so
they don't
interfere with uh air travel next we
gotta talk about the grc that we saw in
falcon in the winter soldier
[Applause]
because like do we think that the global
repatriation council plays a role within
new asgard because the grc was
established post blip to help allocate
resources and maintain refugees
displaced by the blip and the ash
guardians set up new asgard during the
blip and certainly were affected by it
when the snap was undone so do we think
that the grc stepped in with the
asgardians at all i bet they tried to
and you know valkyrie was like now get
out of here we're not about that we
don't need your help we're all good
because yeah we don't know exactly when
new asgard set up we know it was during
the blip it was after the thanos does
his snap that the whoever was left from
the statesman made it to earth probably
following thor or thor helped him get
down here he's running new asgard he's
doing a bad job he's drinking he's
playing too many games you know probably
smoking weed you know they don't put in
the movie he's probably doing it as
guardian greenery
yeah you know he's gotta smoke a lot he
says guardian so some some ass guardians
must have been blipped they come back
if they're not in norway i don't know
where they would blip back to
maybe they maybe they are already there
i'm sure the grc was like you guys need
help and they're like no we're good get
out of here we're not touching our
resources we got all our people back
you're fine go away so i don't think the
grc was
as as instrumental here because they
were probably already set up they
probably already had their
citizenship stat established during the
blip so the grc probably didn't play too
much of a role i don't i doubt it
i would love if they did because like it
would give them more of a role in the
mcu because like you know we we just we
were just introduced to them in falcon
weird soldier and like they weren't
really given a really great reputation
in that show and so we're just like what
is the grc really they're just messing
things up they're not actually helping
people and like the black smashers like
have like some pretty you know
fair grievances um there um but like
it's just i just want to see them be
useful and be like yeah we helped the
asgardians set up like they wouldn't be
able to do it as efficiently if it
wasn't for us um so like i would love to
see that but like i can definitely see
the gardens be like yeah no um odin like
this place we lay claim to this place
and uh that's what we're doing
so you either like it or you don't like
it we see that scene in the trailer with
you know valkyrie and these other world
leaders and they're like arguing at a
table i wonder if one of those is like a
grc representative and everyone's just
like shut up you don't get to sleep okay
you're making us all look bad out here
but yeah no i would love i just want to
see more like grc and like yeah and see
like why
their presence at the mcu is important
and like why we're like like we're just
seeing like the players behind the grc
like who's in charge of the grc and are
they evil because you gotta always ask
in the mcu you gotta ask whoever
organization
hey
in the mcu and in the real life any
government organization are they evil
are they evil are you hydra uh you have
to ask that specifically you have to ask
it i would love if like valkyrie is like
are you hydra and the person was like
it's just sweaty that's suspicious
no
hydra what are you talking about i
haven't even heard about it
that's weird
he just runs out of room
hydra oh that sounds familiar i don't
know
is that like a drink is that a sports
drink i don't know you mean like a fire
hydra hydrant
that's all i know about hydra it's weird
um but yeah no i i think it'd be dope if
they did but like i could totally see
the grc also just being useless and not
really right um being able to touch
these guards because like they're gods
so we have these guardians living on
earth and while they may just be keep
you know shacking up with each other i'm
sure some of them are bound to fall for
a human because let's be real uh
beyonce's still on the planet and uh
yeah you know she's the closest god like
big we have beyonce
so i'm sure one of those asgardians are
going to take a crack uh let's let's be
real watch out jay-z um we've got you
back jay-z
uh we got a whole country of hoves a
whole country of gods but yeah let's
remember some key differences about the
asgardian physiology um number one and
the most important um and most obvious
they live way longer than humans about 5
000 years which is like
that's a lot god like we we can barely
hit like 80 um out here like they're
living five thousand so like well our
lifetime is nothing to that's literally
like
i don't know kindergarten like that's
the kindergarten it's like yeah whatever
i mean if you're an asgardian like set
up some sort of savings account that has
like a pretty good
you know
uh compound interest rate and just get
that money over the years just let it
sit there don't touch it for the first
two do not touch it let it build up
funds okay forty thousand
three million
18 dollars
40 million dollars
and then in your back half of your life
you can really start collecting uh
really start taking some money out of
there your offspring will thank you for
uh your demi god osprey will thank you
for not touching that money um and like
also they are generally stronger and
just heal faster in general and uh some
of them right could potentially perform
magic which is um not something that we
can do i mean
outside of the bedroom am i right brian
oh yeah
[Laughter]
well though we have seen like ned
perform magic right so there are humans
who maybe have innate magical abilities
maybe more than we know
it's just never been brought out of us
before so the performing magic is not
just as guardians they're probably some
humans that could do it
stephen strange did it everyone at
comtaj most of people commentary humans
but yeah you have a lot of as guardians
who already know the magic they know how
to do some magic uh so yeah these are
very powerful people uh with strong
bodies uh strong minds strong souls
maybe doing magic if i was an asgardian
go sign up for the nfl you know what i'm
talking about
you can take a few hits to your head
you're stronger you'll heal up you'll be
fine you can play you could play for a
team for a thousand years
that's just your rookie season you know
what i mean like come on
i would love to see some asgardia like
what has characters be like pretending
to be a normal human it's like yeah i'm
just really strong
think about how this is going to affect
the olympics
oh my god
clean up at the olympics from now on
they're gonna be killing us how do you
test for an ass guardian like do they
pee gold like like pete is coming
hey
i'm not drinking enough water i'll tell
you that right now drink more water if
you've got gold pea out there drink some
water everyone pause the video right now
go drink a glass of water
mt they'll know and as guardian because
as guardians have different physiology
than humans
they're usually way hotter than us
they're way hotter they got denser bones
their their muscle structure's a little
different so like they'd be able to like
scan for asgardians but that would be
messed up if they wouldn't let ice
guardians compete but i could see why i
could see why yeah um i mean like i was
a big fan of smallville growing up and
like one of the biggest problems that
clark had was like not being able to
play football when he loved football and
like because he would just like crush
the competition clark loves football get
out of here you alien you'll get to play
on football go help your dad mow some
grass or some [ __ ] out yeah
yeah
don't do something else sorry you can't
play football
clark kent too bad get over it oh you
got laser eyes who cares go write an
article you nerd i love god-like beings
having to like pull themselves back and
like not like hurt other people so like
i just i just want to see what it's like
and like how strong like your average
asgardian is compared to everyone else
because like they're pretty diesel like
we know like thor is like a thunder
wheel dinner all that but like what is
like your average asgard like how strong
thor is definitely stronger than all the
other asgards but yeah the other one's
pretty strong i mean in the clip or in
the trailer you know we see that battle
kind of going on it looks like it's in
new asgard this is where
you know thor sees uh uh jane for the
first time and in the background you see
like what looked like normal people just
fighting these alien things
bats or whatever and it's like those are
probably just other asgardians who are
like well i work at the grocery store
but i guess i gotta go fight some aliens
right now right
and i'm strong it's like they're
fighting like they're fighting like they
used to do back in new hampshire but
like they're wearing like using them
the norwegians are like what the hell's
going on and the asgardians are like ah
this happens over there
we're used to it it's like the old days
you'll see you'll see
you'll see you'll get used to it could
these asgardians potentially be allowed
to marry and start a family with us
humans could that even be possible well
in the comics loki had a child with a
human woman and named him volley hap
volley halfling
look
halfling
well that's awesome
part of that is like the naming
convention that the asgardians have
right you get like oh you're right
father's name with like a son or
something so i think halfling is because
he is a hybrid he's also known as
he's also known as agamemnon he has like
a real name
but valerie was just the name he got
sorry aka agamemnon so in theory it's
possible that a human and an ass
guardian could start a family together
though one of the parents is going to
vastly outlive the other and who knows
what traits the hybrid offspring would
take from either side so i feel like
it's going to be really complicated um
just uh you know like you're you're
going to be a single parent at one point
in your life yeah no denying yeah it's
interesting and like is the kid gonna
live like a very long time is it oh my
god strong does it get some of like the
strength or you know healing factor that
the parent have we don't really know i
mean it it doesn't seem like in theory
they should be able to
mate but the comics have established it
and one thing i like about marvel comics
uh is they kind of have this idea that
like life was spread throughout the
universe right by the celestials and
it's all the same base dna like deep
deep down right it's kind of the same
genetic structure that's why so many
aliens are like bi
beetle looking
things that look like humans they just
have like pink skin or blue skin or
whatever like the green they kind of
look like humans wow and even in
guardians of the galaxy right we saw
uh john c reilly's character i forget
his name he has like traditional kind of
caucasian skin but his wife has like
pink skin and they have a kid it's like
this idea that like yeah we're from
different planets uh throughout the
universe but we can still
be together and like we can still
procreate because we're the same base
dna so this idea that like you could
have an ass guardian and a human get
together and i hope this comes up at
some point uh and for love and thunder i
know they got a lot to cover if we could
just get like a half hour talking with
the ass guardians that would be great
but yeah this idea that you could have
the kid and like your kid and your
partner are going to outlive you by
thousands of years but it's like i'm in
love right now what am i going to do so
i i mean this would be a crazy thing to
address you know 20 years from now in
the mcu right you have a kid who is half
ass guardian who is now a hero or
something like that like that would be
very interesting to see i really want to
see that hardcore and like you know
considering that we we are getting the
introduction of the greek gods as we see
uh zeus in this trailer and like
hercules is like i feel like it's pretty
much basically confirmed but like it's
not gonna work but like we we basically
know hercules is probably gonna come we
better go very soon
um like in like he's a demigod like i
feel like he's human half god yeah yeah
so like i feel like the conversation has
to like it just makes sense to like
start that conversation in this movie
just be like hey what does it mean to be
a half god half human hybrid and i would
love to see like uh like in the
asgardian
form of of hercules just pop up somehow
and uh if that does pop up i hope it's a
woman because like i would love to see
like a female demigod
so brandon i've got to ask you do we
think the asgardians are officially
citizens of earth and free to roam the
planet as they please yeah i think earth
welcomed them with open arms they've
been taken in they're citizens of norway
or citizens of new asgard they can
probably travel as they see fit some
countries may keep them out but
everyone's keeping tabs on them because
everyone wants to know where they are uh
and i've been a few of them maybe even
left i think i think most of them would
want to live in new asgard because
they're used to being around these
people and they have such a shared
experience and the culture and
everything but i bet a few of them are
probably like through this i'm out of
here i'm going to go live in kansas or
i'm going to go live in california or
something i'm gonna go live in france
uh so maybe a few of them got away and
are living where they want but i i bet
most of them are in new asgard but i'm
sure they can travel as they want which
is very interesting they're i wonder if
they're celebrities kind of like we were
talking about the boys earlier
we're talking about the boys i'm mixing
inside marvel um
whoops uh yeah it's sort of like the
boys in a way like i wonder if they're
like like celebrities and be like all
right i'm just really cool because i'm a
god like oh follow me because like and
like it's sort of like the new way of
following a god i feel like they have
instagrams and like they're just like
all these huge social personalities that
have to roam the planet that's great a
few of them are definitely influencers
that's for sure empty there is a couple
of influencers sure i feel like
enchantress we'll probably have like a
whole following on instagram or
something and like secretly be doing
evil stuff uh human social media
oh yeah
they'd be like what's up guys it's me
it's mushheim i'm out here i'm on
vacation right now in germany having a
great time it's oktoberfest you know my
first couple thousand years were pretty
boring but i'm glad to be on earth now
having a great time uh be sure to check
out all my links uh and like and
subscribe in the batman like during that
moment where like the riddler
he's like thanks for subscribing guys
like that was hilarious like yeah that
was my favorite part so let's do that
for the mcu but with gods hey be sure to
check out newrockstarsmerch.com to see
all of our awesome merch options even if
you're not a god if you are a god you
look even better with our shirts on it's
a great way to support all of our
awesome work we do on the channel and we
dropped our newest limited edition
latest obsession shirt inspired by the
new obi one series if you buy this shirt
you'll unlock the ability to get a
custom shout out that will appear on our
weekly wikileaks show hosted by eric
voss and tommy bechtore and like all of
our latest obsession merch it will sell
out fast and it will not last forever so
head on over to new rockstars.com today
to grab yours before it's lost to the
sands of tatooine forever we're going to
bury it with the lightsabers and you're
never going to see it until
you know bail organa needs your help all
right that's that's the only way you're
going to see it again but before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help bring
big question to you people like upside
from cringing at the pump to getting an
eye popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts especially baymax he
inflates all the time
that's why at new rockstars we've
started using upside upside is an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or even just dines out with
every purchase you earn cash back thanks
to upside and you can use that cashback
to buy the perfect souvenir on your next
road trip so to get started download the
free upside app in the app store or
google play just use the promo code big
question and get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of 10
or more in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with upside
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands upside users are
earning more than a million dollars
every week that's probably why they have
a 4.8 star rating on the app store so
download the free upside app and use
promo code big question to get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of 10 or more that is five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more using
promo code big question all one word no
spaces at checkout all right now it is
time for our bite size question are you
ready brandon oh i'm ready for a little
bite size
i hope your stomach is empty it does not
have any food in it because the bite
size questions are starving for some
bite size questions
well here we go first question brennan
how did hulk even end up on sakaar in
thor ragnarok in the first place that's
a great question mt uh if we remember
all the way back to thor ragnarok our
beloved god of thunder found himself
imprisoned by the grand master and
forced to battle for his freedom and who
did he wind up facing off against wyatt
is good buddy hulk of course
a friend from work a friend from work
when thor and hulk chat later hulk
explains in rather rudimentary hand
signals that he wound up once a car via
a crash
uh presumably of the quinjet uh because
if you remember uh back even further in
the mcu the last time we had seen hulk
uh before this moment was during the
events of avengers age of ultron which
was back in 2015 after tossing ultron
from a quinjet he activates stealth mode
so he can't be tracked by anyone and he
flies off into the sunset just like he's
batman at the end of the dark knight
trilogy being like i'm done being batman
you guys are on your own now
screw off
i'm going to friends with anne hathaway
goodbye
i'm going to france you guys still have
villains but i'm leaving
not my problem bye
but how did hulk get from earth's
atmosphere to sakaar we know that not
only hulk but the quinjet itself made it
all the way to the car because we see it
there in the junkyard and then thor goes
on it uh so
both of them made it all the way there
it's not like thor got uh abducted by
yondu at some point and taken to cigar
the whole thing was taken there so a lot
of people were wondering this in an
interview with cinema blend back in 2017
production designer dan henna confirmed
one part of this long journey and that
would be a wormhole how did you get out
the devil's anus right
when talking about how hulk got us the
car dan said quote the car is populated
by aliens and the sky in sakaar has a
number of wormholes that deposits space
waste basically if you're flying through
space you can get caught up in a
wormhole and you can end up well he hits
one of these wormholes and he ended up
here and he became the grandmaster
special toy so that's how hulk got there
it was a wormhole that's fine but
but now i have so many more questions
right was this wormhole like near earth
like or was it far away uh how come no
one on earth has noticed this wormhole
perhaps it was a temporary wormhole that
like opened and closed and where was
hulk even going in the first place right
seriously he's like getting away i i
assumed he was going to like hide
somewhere on earth but maybe he was like
i'm going to go fly into the sun like
i'm icarus or something or i'm going
gonna go fly on the moon and see if i
die who knows we may never know the full
story unless they decide to do a series
on disney plus covering hulk's time
before ragnarok but at least we can
confirm that the wormhole was the the
main mode of travel at some point hulk
and his quinjet go into a wormhole and
wind up once a car and they're there for
a couple years
i think it must have been a temporary
wormhole that opened up near earth it
just happened to be that way but that
makes me think did someone make this
happen was there like a a god type
figure that wanted hulk to get this a
car did the grand master have any
ability to open up a wormhole and suck
in the hulk because he could sense him
flying through space i don't know like
did the celestials make this happen it
just seems like it's a it's a really big
question that they've never really
answered other than just saying oh it's
a wormhole and he got there considering
that you know thor ragnarok is a sequel
to for the dark world i wonder if like
there's still some like gravity
like oh that's a great idea from the
convergence
yeah maybe there was like a weird ripple
i like that that's interesting like that
and like it's like all right you're
going to a different part of the
universe because like that's what these
weird convergence holes do yeah i wonder
what the plan was for hulk it's like all
right like i'm just gonna go into space
though we do know in um age of ultron
that like after he hooked out and
destroyed that um wait he destroyed all
that area fighting tony stark um he
looks at everyone he's like oh [ __ ] what
did i do yeah right before tony knocks
him out he's like
everyone thinks i'm a monster and i feel
like that probably motivated hulk's like
all right i'm gonna leave because well i
also wonder because ultron was in this
quinjet with with the casket or whatever
right i wonder if ultron he wanted to
take over earth and get rid of the
humans blah blah blah but he was going
to like destroy the planet i wonder if
ultron was like had found the wormhole
and like programmed it into the quinjet
he's like i'm gonna go destroy earth and
then we'll go check out this wormhole
and see what that's all about and hold
just like beep beep beep and like flew
into the wormhole because ultron had
pre-programmed it into the into the
navigation oh my god i i love that idea
of
ultron like wanting to go to sakaar like
through a warm world because we saw in
what if that he does actually go to the
car to destroy the grand master's right
the spot yeah i would like i love that a
lot it's like all right this was my plan
the entire time yeah to go to the summit
you're welcome
rockstars has given you this gift well
let's talk about the gift of gills next
because we had an injured second
bite-sized question does neymour the the
submariner himself have eels yes we're
gonna hopefully be learning a lot more
about neymar and the next black panther
finger cross but neymar mckenzie aka the
submariner is infamous for ruling the
atlanteans and being so easy to piss off
man you can kiss that guy off real
easily he is the mutant son of a human
father and an atlantean princess so he's
able to both breathe on land like a
human and breathe underwater via gills
behind his ears like all the other
atlanteans so he's got these gills back
here um all the atlanteans or homo
mermanus have superhuman strength but
neymar is even stronger than that just
like thor is stronger than all the other
asgardians neymar is like way stronger
than all the other atlanteans it's
likely due to his hybrid and mutant
nature that he got this extra strength
he can also fly which
most attribute to his mutant power
though nobody is quite sure how it works
because like most mutants right they
have something that enables their flight
like magneto right he manipulates
magnetic fields to fly jean grey she's
using like telepathy instead to fly uh
angel of course has wings now neymar he
has developed little vestigial wings
they're like down near his ankles are
cute they look so
stupid look so they look adorable but as
far as anybody could tell
those those little wings they're not
making him fly they're so tiny right
and he and this guy can like fly as fast
as a jet like he he flies fast
yes they think these little wings on his
feet are more for like maneuvering and
steering than actual flying but yeah his
mutant power is just a flight i mean
neymar the character of neymar is super
old in marvel comics he's like a very
old character so he kind of has these
golden age silver age abilities that are
not quite
sussed out all the way he does have
gills he could breathe underwater you
could breathe on land he's got all that
stuff and the atlanteans themselves are
kind of crazy because there's like 10
different ways that they don't adapted
to breathe underwater it kind of depends
on which story you read like one is like
it just kind of happened because like
they were underwater and they're like we
can breathe now one was like god gave
them the power to do it uh one was like
they're actually aliens from another
planet and they've been hiding on earth
the whole time all these crazy theories
but yes neymar has got gills baby we
know that much to be true the gift of
gills are his he has the gift of guilt
uh i wish i had gills because uh
swimming would be a lot more easier and
um i'd be less terrified of it
um but now it's time for our box of
scraps questions
you're better than a cable
brandon if you could watch one film from
the mcu for the first time again which
film or project would it be and why this
is from a crispy crispy a discord by the
way yes thank you crispy crusty this was
a great question so i threw this one in
there i mean the obvious answer right is
end game like what a foot what a blast
that was the big battle at the end but
that's that's too easy that's too easy
for me to say i will that's like to me
that's like all-time qb right that's
always going to be the one you wish you
could watch it again for the first time
for the thrill the tingles in your neck
as as
as cap picks up mjolnir right like you
wish you could see it again um but i
think well i was thinking about this
question like so many great memories uh
for watching these movies from the first
time but really the one i would love to
go back and see again for the first time
uh would be guardians of the galaxy oh
my god yes that was the one for me like
i was impressed with iron man obviously
when avengers happened i was like
they'll never pull this off and they
pulled it off it was great but guardians
of the galaxy was always the joke that i
would tell my friends i was like yeah
they're making a thor movie but they'll
never make guardians of the galaxy
that's crazy and man i sat in that movie
theater i laughed i cried and i was
completely blown away uh and that from
that moment on i was like they're
they're set this this is gonna go on
forever like they can make these movies
and they're so good at it uh so yeah
that would be the one i would love to
see again for the first time it was so
good yeah i know guardians is like that
that was a shift that changed the whole
game and like i no one had any
expectations for guards on that galaxy
no
that was the best part of seeing it for
the first time it's like you had no idea
like for the most part who the any of
these people were and like it was
meeting these heroes for the first time
it was like so magical that like yeah
now that we already know and they're
already established like one of the most
popular teams of the mcu you can't
really go back to that so like yeah i
agree 100
um guardians is a good one that's a good
one um but you know for me i i think i
think it's gonna have to be
winter soldier for me and like yeah i
feel like that's like an easy answer but
like my god winter soldier was like the
movie now that got me to like
really fall in love with the mcu like i
loved the mcu before but like i had no i
didn't respect captain america until
winter soldier i'm like this is a good
man he's a loyal friend and like he does
what's right no matter what i'm like i
freaking love that i had no idea with
the hydra twist with um with a shield
and all that so like my jaw
was to the ground and i was like you can
we not trust
anybody in shield anymore was colson
evil i had no idea so like having all
those questions in my mind was just like
the best so like i would say winner's
older but that is it for this episode a
big question i want to thank my brother
the amazing brandon for joining me this
episode please follow him at grinnette
on twitter it's amazing you can follow
me at mastertainment on twitter if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
like some really wild theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
here on youtube and on all social media
platforms and make sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video and of course the new rockstars
discord is a thing and it is popping and
don't forget to join us by hitting that
link in the description box below to
just have fun conversations with us on
discord it's really fun um but yeah
thank you guys so much for watching we
love you we'll see you guys next time
okay bye
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]